my name is Logan broadband and I'm a
competitive boomerang thrower I'm a
three-time world Boomerang champion with
the US team I've been a second in the
world of the past two World Cups as an
individual and and I'm best known for
doing a backflip catch all right guys so
I'm gonna teach you how to make a really
great working rumor ring at home all
right so this is a room ring it's
something that you can actually throw
and catch inside your kitchen or your
living room at home here's where you're
gonna need you're gonna need a couple
pieces of cardstock this is about 65
pounds of cardstock we've got a glue
stick and scissors that's basically it
so what you're gonna do is you're gonna
go to Logan Broadbent calm and you'll be
able to print off a template for a rumor
ring and what you're gonna do is you're
gonna cut that out and you're gonna
trace it on the cardstock all right so
let's trace this guy alright perfect
there we have a room rang trace and now
what we're gonna do is we're actually
going to put two pieces of cardstock
together that's gonna give it just the
right amount of weight and thickness to
actually return really well and we're
gonna go ahead and cut out that shape
[Music]
okay now we have our two pieces of
cardstock in a perfectly shaped rumour
egg shape and what you want to do is you
want to try not to bend the paper as
you're cutting it out you want it to
remain as flat as possible because what
we're going to do next is we're gonna
glue these two pieces together and then
we're gonna add the air foils which is
going to allow it to return any type of
Bend and the paper is going to affect
the flight of the boomerang so let's
grab our glue stick and glue these two
pieces together
here we go so I'd like to use a glue
stick because you can get a really nice
even coating on the boomerang so that
you get a really nice even application
to hold the pieces of paper together
without adding too much weight or
saturating the paper which makes it
soggy and doesn't fly well alright next
step is to actually make this what looks
almost like a boomerang into an actual
boomerang right now it's two-dimensional
returning boomerangs are actually three
dimensional right they're going to have
an airfoil which allows it to return so
now we're going to make this boomerang
comeback by adding an airfoil if you're
a right-handed thrower you're gonna bend
the wing down at this angle if you're a
left-handed thrower you're gonna bend
the wing down at this angle so I like to
use the edge of the table to do this so
you find the edge of the table you find
that angle and you bend it down just
slightly that's all it takes just a very
slight little Bend you'll do that with
each wing at the same angle okay and
okay and now the last thing that we're
gonna do is we're gonna give this
boomerang just a little bit of dihedral
which means we're gonna bend the wing up
just slightly allowing it to fly a
little bit higher and then to float down
and boom there we go
this should work as long as I throw it
correctly I'm gonna write top right on
the center of the boomerang so I know
which side of the boomerang is facing me
we always want to throw with the top
side facing us and all we have to do is
make a fist pinch the boomerang just
like this really lightly and then just
like we're knocking on a door we're
gonna throw straight up and down and
hopefully this comes back let's give it
a shot here we go boom just like that
cool right you can actually use a cereal
box to do this you can use cardstock you
can use all sorts of materials the ones
that I have are actually made out of
polyethylene just the high-impact
plastic so they're a little more durable
but the paper ones are really fun to